nuevamente el break city sus efectos en
la región británica de irlanda del norte
vuelven a enfrentar a londres y bruselas
desde que se hizo efectivo este divorcio
el primero de enero de este año todos
los bienes alimenticios y productos que
se envíen desde cualquier ciudad
británica a dentro del mismo país son
considerados un tipo de exportación dado
que irlanda del norte permanece dentro
de la unión europea el mercado único de
la unión europea eso hace que haya
traumatismos en el ingreso de alimentos
lo que dicen está generando traumatismos
y escasez de alimentos básicos por ello
hoy el gobierno británico en el
parlamento pidió oficialmente a la unión
europea renegociar este protocolo de
irlanda del norte- delort frost el
ministro encargado de estos temas en el
gobierno dijo no podemos seguir así
pidió cancelar todas las acciones
legales y periodos de gracia y también
pidió un periodo de inactividad la unión
europea ya ha dicho que no renegociará
el acuerdo break city especialmente este
protocolo de irlanda del norte el primer
ministro boris johnson
también ha amenazado con suspender
unilateralmente este protocolo de
irlanda del norte así que formalmente ha
iniciado una nueva batalla un nuevo
capítulo de esta larga batalla entre
londres y bruselas